not really I mean it's Church of England
which is the old Anglican you know
pretty strict religion not much anymore
you know there's a lot of immigration
now and a lot of them are Catholic
there's a lot of poles there are a lot
of Eastern Europeans and so that's where
the immigration that's where religion
would be increasing and Islam is
increasing because there's more Muslim
immigrants as well but they they're
shocked by American you know the
American religious right now they can't
believe that people exist you have the
Ten Commandments on their on their front
lawns and who are saying that Iraq is
God's will and that makes them kind of
sick actually
well he did it after he left office his
wife is Catholic and I think you know he
honestly is a kind of spiritual guy you
know he really for all that you might
think he made terrible terrible mistakes
you know I'm not allowed to say cuz I'm
new reporter but um for all you think
that a rock might have been a terrible
terrible thing I honestly believe that
he thought it was the right thing to do
morally I think he felt there was an
obligation to to get rid of Saddam
Hussein and I think while he was in
office he couldn't convert to
Catholicism because it would have been
seen as a big deal politically um and
I'm not sure it's because he didn't want
to alienate Anglicans I think it's just
it would have detracted distracted from
his job and all the other stuff he was
doing but is kind of shocking cuz it
makes you look backwards and think or
you know or some of the decisions he
made is that because he was already a
Catholic or whatever you just don't
really know but he did it pretty quietly
and he it seemed you know again if you
sort of at least respect someone for for
following through on their own
principles it was a commendable thing